okay so yeah we're going to do our final
session in the in the model selection
um uh chapter and we're going to look at
Ridge regression and lassu and once
again we're using our markdown in in our
studio that will help us create a nice
document at the end of the session and
as you as we've seen it's just as simple
as as having a script but it's better
because you get nice annotation at the
end of the day
so let's have a look at the screen and
see our heading we got Ridge regression
in the lasso and for this we're going to
use the package glimnet
eliminates a package that that I
actually manage on on cran and it's it's
been created by myself Jerome Friedman
and Rob titrani for fitting lassu models
Ridge models and a whole class of models
in between
elasticnet which we won't cover in this
class and and and for a lot of different
loss functions so we can do logistic
regressions ordinary regressions and and
a variety and a variety of other models
we'll be using ordinary regression yet
yeah so we'll run Library glimnet
and
limit
um doesn't use a formula language
um so we're required to give it a matrix
X of predictors and and a response
Vector in this case so we create those
um by using methods by which by this
time we know how so we make an X and A Y
which is the the predictor Matrix and
the response
and we'll first fit a a ridge regression
model
so column that's got a alpha argument
and Alpha equals one is lassu and Alpha
equals zero is Ridge and if you look on
the help file you'll you'll see
instructions and how to on some of the
other arguments and for Alphas in
between zero and one you get what's
called elastic net models which are in
between Ridge and lesue but for us now
we'll just focus on Alpha equals zero
which is Ridge
and so
we do that and it it comes back um very
quickly laminates extremely fast and
this isn't a big data set so it's
especially fast
let's use a plot method for a glimnet
object
and this is kind of interesting it makes
a plot
um
as a function of log of Lambda
and what it's plotting are the
coefficients
so if you go back to the to the the
lectures on on on Ridge regression and
lassu you'll see that the models are
penalized according Ridge regressions
penalized by the sum of squares of the
coefficients so penalties put on the sum
of squares of the coefficients and
that's controlled by parameter Lambda
so the Criterion for
for Ridge regression is
residual sum of squares which is the
usual for for linear regression
plus Lambda times the summation J equals
1 to p
of beta J squared
so it's trying to minimize the residual
sum of squares
but
it's been modified by a penalty on the
sum of squares of the coefficients
so if Lambda is Big you're going to want
the sum of squares of the coefficients
to be small so that'll shrink the
coefficients towards zero
and as Lambda gets very big the
coefficients will all be zero
and so what limited does is it it
actually develops a whole path of models
on a grid of values of Lambda quite a
fine grid about 100 values of Lambda and
so we see here on the log scale when
Lambda log of Lambda is 12
all the coefficients are essentially
zero then as we relax Lambda the
coefficients grow away from zero in a
nice smooth way
and and they get
the sum of squares of the coefficients
is getting bigger and bigger until we
reach a point where lambdas have
effectively zero and the coefficients
are unregularized and so these would be
the coefficients that you get from an
ordinary least squares fit
of these variables so glymnet will
create the whole path of variables
so unlike subset and and forward
stepwise regression which controls the
complexity of a model by by restricting
the number of variables Rich regression
keeps all the variables in and shrinks
the coefficients towards zero
okay
so
it gives a whole path we need to
pick a value along the path and limits
got a built-in function called CV dot
limit that'll do
cross validation for your k-fold
cross-validation and so we'll run CV dot
Ridge stand by default 10-fold
cross-validation and then we can do a
plot there's a plot method for that and
gives you a nice plot of the
cross-validated mean squared error and
there it goes and you see it dips down
in the beginning the mean squared area
is very high the coefficients are
restricted to be too small and then at
some point it kind of levels off this
seems to indicate that the the full
model is is doing a good job
um there's two vertical line years the
one is at the minimum and the other
vertical line is at one standard error
of the of the minimum within one
standard error so it's a slightly more
restricted model that does almost as
well as the minimum and sometimes we'll
go for that
and at the top here it's indicating that
at all stages there's all 20 variables
in the model so that's our 19 variables
plus the intercept
so that's Ridge regression using glimnet
let's use a lasso model now if you
recall the lassu was
was similar to Ridge regression the only
thing that was different was the penalty
so let's get the pin on you
so for lassu we minimize the residual
sum of squares plus Lambda and it's a
very subtle change
we've got J equals 1 to P instead of the
sum of squares of the coefficients we
penalize the absolute values of the
coefficients
it's also controlling the size of the
coefficients
and it seems like absolute value and and
sum of squares would be rather similar
but the lassus got a somewhat magical
quality and by penalizing the absolute
values that's actually going to restrict
some of the coefficients to be exactly
zero
Okay so
oh we gotta get back to our control here
so let's run that again it fits the
whole path
and when we make the plot
against the log of Lambda indeed what
you see
is that
initially all the coefficients are zero
and then the first coefficient seems to
be a purple there's a pair of them there
and then the blue one's been zero up to
this point then it jumps in then this
red one jumps in so you see the
coefficients jumping
um having been zero for a length of the
path and at the top of the plot we
actually see as a function of Lambda as
well how many non-zero variables are in
the model
so as we saw in the lectures
La Sue is is doing shrinkage and
variable selection
when we put the lasso using glimnet we
didn't tell it Alpha because the default
for Alpha is 1 which gives you the less
two
um we plotted the lasso against X far
equals Lambda if you look at the help
file for the plot you'll see that
there's various choices and one of them
is a really interesting choice
and it's deviance and what it means is
a percentage of deviants explained or
percentage of
um in in case of regression your sum of
squares explained which is the r squared
so if we make that plot
it's changed the orientation and at the
bottom of yeah we it says fraction of
deviance explained so that's like the r
squared right and
what do you find out here is that
a lot of the r squared was explained for
quite heavily shrunk
coefficients and towards the end with a
relatively small increase in r squared
from between 0.4 and 0.5 coefficients
grow very large and so this may be an
indication that at the end of the path
is overfitting
so these different ways of plotting the
coefficients
give you different information about the
coefficients and and about the nature of
the path
we can use cross-validation again
and
and plot it and see years cross
validation for the lasso
and it's telling us that the best model
the minimum cross-validation here is
that for size 15
and within one standard error we have a
model of size about six
right and it's somewhat flat in between
and
and so we may make our choice based on
that
um there's a coefficient function
extractive that works on a
cross-validation object and it remember
the the
fit.lassu will have the whole path of
coefficients so it's got roughly 100
coefficient vectors depending on each
value indexed by different values of
Lambda but if we extract the coefficient
from the CV object it'll pick the
coefficient Vector corresponding to the
best model which in this
in this case was was a the model of size
um
well let's see what size one two three
four five so I I guess it's it's picked
the model
it's picked this model over here
so it's within one standard error of the
minimum
so it's it's erring on the more
parsimonious side we know that the the
cross validation error is measured with
with some variance and and so that's
that's the the model that's actually
chosen
all right
um
we'll end the session by
using our earlier validation Training
Division
to use a validation set to to select the
the lasso model
and that's also easy to do so we've
still got our variable train hanging
around index variable so we'll fit the
path of lasso models using X train and Y
train
and
you can do a summary of the foot it
actually tells us
the summary of a of of a gliminate fit
for each of the models in the path it
gives you the degrees of freedom which
is the number of non-zero coefficients
the percentage deviance explained which
is like r squared for generalized linear
models but this case it's squared error
loss so that's just r squared on the
Square little loss scale and the Lambda
value that corresponded to that that fit
and it it actually tries to fit a a
hundred values of Lambda but if it
reaches a point where nothing much is
changing like you can see nothing much
is changing here it stops
because it's not really making any
progress so as Lambda is getting smaller
here the model is really not changing
it's pretty much at this at the
the ordinary least squares fit the
unpenalized model
okay
so now we can make predictions on our
left out data so that's indexes X by
minus train much like we did before
and if we do demo predict there's 83
observations in the validation set
and we've got 89 values of Lambda so
there's going to be 89 different columns
in this prediction Matrix
here's an interest in
um
little command here we we want to
compute our sum of squared errors
well y minus train is a vector of length
83 but pred is a matrix 83 by 89 and
here we happily say y minus train minus
spread
well what it does is it recycles this
Vector 89 times and it does it column
wise so that can compute this difference
so the result of this here is a matrix
that's 83 by 89
um even though we only gave y's a vector
it recycled it which is it's kind of a
trick but it's a handy trick
we Square those errors
we then use apply to compute the means
in each column of the squared errors and
we put that in and then we take the
square root so there's a whole bunch of
commands all in one there and and now we
can plot that
and as a function of Lambda
and we see a nice
validation curve it goes down and then
climbs up again
this will be overfitting this is under
fitting and this seems to be The Sweet
Spot over here
and we can extract the best Lambda
and yeah
do this by
indexing
there's a component on the on the
laminate object
called Lambda so this extracts that
component then I index it by order of R
MSE so that's our root meat squared
error
order puts them in in ascending order
and so we want the the first the index
of the first or the smallest value and
that'll pick up the best Lambda
so that's that's a way of doing that and
we find the best Lambda is 19.98
and so now we can look at the
coefficients corresponding to that
variable and that will give us a subset
of the coefficients
and the dots correspond to the zeros so
those are the ones that are missing and
so they're not not missing but they're
zeros this is actually printed out in
what's known as sport a sparse Matrix
format and so
which means only the anonymousing values
oh it's only the non-zero values are
actually recorded
so there's our coefficient vector
and that's and that's the end of the
session
so to summarize we've
in the last few sessions
we've uh We've looked at model selection
we've looked at a variety of different
methods best subset forward step wise
Rich regression lassu we've used
validation sets to to select models
we've used CP to select models and we've
also used k-fold cross-validation
we've also seen how to use our markdown
to actually produce a nice
recording of everything we've done
and we hit the knit HTML at the top of
the the pager and this is for the the
entire set of sessions on model
selection and you get a really nice
summary of everything you've done all
the output all the plots nicely
formatted and it makes for a good report
think about if you're doing a data
analysis for a for a client this is a
really nice way of of uh of showing the
output it shows what you did and the
results of what you did
um and so that's available it's a web
page and so you can distributed the link
to that web page you can put it in a
blog you can do what you like with it
what we didn't cover was uh
principal component regression and
partially squares
there's a lab in the end of the chapter
but by now you'll have learned enough
tools you'll be able to go through that
that lab on your own